another headache for president biden on
the foreign policy front which reports
that china caught u.s intelligence by
surprise after testing a nuclear-capable
hypersonic missile
that is so fast it can evade america's
defensive capabilities
the white house being criticized for its
response that it quote
welcomed stiff competition
china denies it tested a hypersonic
missile and says it was a spacecraft the
gop senator lindsey graham isn't buying
that
so when you have the joe biden greatly
set list broken border rise of terrorism
rampant inflation you can now put on the
list nuclear arms race with china which
we're losing
weakness breeds aggression
adding to the problems north korea
reportedly just test fired a submarine
launch ballistic missile
katie um
is it not bipartisan failure on this
front with with china
north korea i mean we i was in congress
when we were attacked on 9 11 it was
bipartisan a lack of imagination
i get the partisanship but what should
we be doing differently now that we know
this
well i think deterrence is one thing i
mean president biden hasn't really given
any indication that he's willing to
stand up for the country you had the
press secretary yesterday saying but we
welcome the competition when this is a
very serious weapon that generals are
saying changes the entire game when it
comes to how we look at nuclear
deterrence whether we have a first
strike option anymore
and with our allies which have been
questioning joe biden's uh
capabilities especially in the aftermath
of afghanistan um they're looking at
this and going well if the united states
is behind in defending itself on a
missile launch that's supersonic uh
they're going to be behind and banning
with us and be able to defend nations
like taiwan for example so president
biden made the decision to leave
afghanistan a lot of americans and
intelligence and foreign policy experts
said that was a good idea in order to
focus on threats like china and north
korea now whether he's capable of
shifting and doing that he hasn't really
given that publicly yet and the idea
that the intelligence community again is
surprised on a third major thing in the
last nine months i think concerns a lot
of people in terms of what their
priorities are dana you've been in the
white house when these kinds of things
not like this but you've seen you've had
to react and adjust what should she have
done differently what should they have
been talking about in terms of messaging
after hearing after learning what we
learned and after admitting that they
were surprised at our intelligence well
i think that's the thing i would love to
see some someone do a
a media interview or maybe a
congressional hearing those get kind of
boring but i do think that if you are
giving the intelligence community x
billion of dollars a year
and then the quote anonymous quote from
the intelligence community is whoa what
just happened we had no idea this was
going on we deserve to understand what
the investment is that we're making in
the intelligence community that we can
miss something so obvious is this and it
makes you wonder what else are we
possibly missing and
the adversaries are going to continue to
test us and what our complete and total
foreign policy focus under the biden
administration is about climate change i
think it is just like everything that
they're focused on there's a meeting
coming at the end of this month in
glasgow they're so focused on it and
they want so much to be able to go to
the meeting saying that we're we have an
agreement to pass this legislation that
will get us to x amount of carbon
emissions when china and russia india
they're they're not paying attention to
this they're they're just blowing it off
jesse uh president trump certainly
ushered in and demanded a paradigmatic
approach a different approach to china
uh and i give him credit for that i
don't think he did much substantively um
i think but it was a lot to get the
country to think differently um i think
it's bipartisan this failure but if not
where do you give credit to president
trump and where do you give credit
president biden and more importantly
again what should we be doing
well as i said yesterday i gave biden
credit for the alliance between the uk
and australia against china even though
he didn't know anything about it and i
give trump credit for waking this
country up to the threat of china i do
too and this is definitely destabilizing
because it's trans continental you slap
a warhead on it it explodes right over
los angeles goodbye los angeles it's
kind of like a strategic deterrent
though it's not tactical so they're
basically warning us we can wipe out
seattle san francisco
and you guys have 30 seconds to
intercept this thing that's tough so
what we need to do now you go to star
wars it's the only way you're going to
confront something like this that way
you basically shoot the thing out of the
sky mid-flight right as it dips below
the orbit level and that's how you take
it out it's incredibly expensive to do
star wars and joe seems more interested
in the green new deal so he's going to
have to make a decision whether he wants
to do that or not but i mean there is
good news here and this is uh just one
that was 20 miles off in the test that's
a big deal but they said it was pretty
good those experts did
20 miles off is a long way and it could
take five years to get this program
operational and we are like 50 years
ahead of the chinese when it comes to
the nuclear arms race and we have ships
and subs that can just splatter china
with nuclear weapons right off the coast
line i'm not worried about that
the big thing with china though is their
population's over
they have
the slowest growing population in world
history the biggest gender gap in world
history because they killed all the
women there's no women in that country
and because of all this urbanization
i think they're going to lose 50 percent
of their population by 2050. so we just
wait these guys out and hope she doesn't
do anything crazy like launch a missile
like this
um craig we spent a lot of money to win
the cold war
there were democrats that quarreled with
it there were republicans that supported
it a lot of things came out of that
including uh we that wall came down
communism suffered a defeat uh we new
technologies emerge how do should we
marshal the same kind of effort or
should say try to attract the same kind
of support from countries to go against
china uh uh uh from an economic
standpoint a military standpoint and to
to jesse's point i think we're gonna
have to as a country understand it
defense spending is gonna have to go way
up and we're going to have to think more
imaginatively about how we defend
ourselves i agree but i think all of you
are way way too pessimistic i know that
the rocket is alarming but we are
kicking the crap out of china in
diversity training installing
gender-neutral bathrooms and don't get
me started on the windmills we got way
more windmills than they do look
they build them for us they build them
for us
and the solar panels yeah i don't think
china
is going to bomb us anytime soon because
they don't need to we're destroying
ourselves
trying to just expose the folly of our
priorities it's no longer about
competing with a superpower like china
for us it's dismantling the superpower
that is us right we are our own enemy
now we're uh initiating a destruction
from within china is simply gonna wait
us out until we're finished the number
one the number one enemy in america is
america and it's not all joe's fault
china has the advantage of not being
saddled with an academic establishment
that hates its own country uh they don't
produce social justice warriors that
want to dismantle this world and bring
us back to the dark ages in fact i mean
china smartly encourages woke-ism you
know in the businesses that they do work
with from america because they know that
it handicaps our country so all we all
they're doing right there they're just
doing what they're what they're supposed
to do because they know that we're on
this trajectory where we have we're
beyond naval gazing we've got our heads
way up there
i'll tell you you're right they they
don't they they don't encourage it
because they squash it and they they
will kill people
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else